journée d'émissions de divertissement
gentiment mon cerveau jusqu'au camp
d'avoir voulu tenir bon une vierge est
avec nous à ramon moundir il ya du
budget dans la musique colle bah là on a
mis un voile avait fait entrer l'accusé
dans la commune vi remercie en tout cas
de venir menacer moi en ce moment mais
c'est vrai merci de venir me dire
moundir
on va revenir je sais pas fabrice éboué
si vous êtes au courant vous dire qu'on
aime beaucoup dans l'émission j'ai dit
tu viens de lui tout le temps dans cette
émission d'oublier ça fait mal moundir
vous avait fracassé dans une interview
non mais vous pouvez dire toute la
vérité on le fait aussi on dit gg leurs
conneries on dit souvent je ne sais si
on va un scandale extrait de de moundir
s'il vous plaît regarder coeur ne touche
pas à mon poste
ils ont trop tendance à s'acharner
gratuitement alors que eux mêmes ne le
feront pas mieux quoi ils te balance des
trucs qui quittions qui ont rien à voir
les mecs de télé réalité se font
insulter
j'ai entendu des mots qui l'âge par
contre je vous dirais pas mais des mots
horribles je dire s'il n'aime pas ces
gens là n'en parlait pas faites-nous pas
chez moi et toi tu as ta 70 ans et
chroniqueur de nous fait pas chier alors
voilà moundir alors bon là ça nous fait
rire non mais c'est vrai à ans qui a
acquis vous en voulez à gilles verdez
non c'est pas du tout âge et berlin mais
je vais venir un peu à monsieur que
j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs
je suis pas chroniqueur rien avoir accès
en fait l'interview qui a été fait
c'était suite à votre émission du 12
septembre lorsque l'un des collègues que
j'appelle le sergent garcia je me suis
un peu comme ici laurent petit régis nos
projets mais voilà ce qui est à dieu de
ne pas prendre la parole quand même et
qu'est ce qu'il avait dit il avait dit
qu'on était des candidats maso pour un
pour un public sadique et si c est donc
là ce n'est pas une analyse c'est une
alliance dégueulasse pourriez pas
fondées si tu m'appelles mon chat je
vais t'appeler ma petite litière donc
d'abord moi je me suis senti vexé
ouais d'accord donc en insultant
effectivement le public de maso
forcément ça touche aussi mes parents
étant les proches sur ce qu'on a vécu et
mon intention d'aller dire tout le monde
donne son avis si on n'est pas tous
d'accord voyez donc il ya des gens qui
défendent cologna son avis il n'y a pas
de souci mais dire que nous nous sommes
des aventuriers maso je suis pas
d'accord c'est pas donner son avis c'est
insulter et à ce moment là on n'est plus
dans le cadre du journalisme et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que j'en
revient justement à toi ne touchez pas
comme ça y va non merci je comprends pas
qu'un grand monsieur comme vous
effectivement à vous êtes auteur de
plusieurs ouvrages au niveau du sport et
moi qui suis un ancien sportif en plus
avec un vous avez le prix littéraire
politique justement d'edgar faure et
ouais je votre intervention parfois je
la trouve un peu démesuré j'ai
l'impression que même à côté de pierre
bellemare dans les enquêtes impossibles
c'est l'impression de voir doigt c'est
c'est vraiment le truc que je comprends
pas c'est à dire pourquoi tant de morts
pourquoi encore tant de sacrifices
jamais ça sur moi dire ils donnent leur
avis sur l'émission en évoquant ce
qu'est ce qui ce qui se passe la vie
d'anna jeudi que des fois il défend si
gilles verdez défendu quand il y en a
plein qui était contre moi par les
choses
je sais pas ce qui lui a fermé à maera
et ce jour il est bien sûr le dos et non
mais on voulait juste vous dire un truc
moi parce qu'on va pas faire de zohra
dessus moi je voulais vous dire nous
nous on n'a rien contre vos plus on vous
aime beaucoup et on est un petit peu
blessés voilà que vous vous en preniez à
l'émission c'est pour ça alors je me
suis pas prêt à l'émission encore une
fois est ni sur toi et d'ailleurs si tes
collègues auraient fait un petit peu
plus leur boulot ils auraient vu que sur
le figaro lorsque je fais une interview
j'ai dit que je ne dis rien contre toi
ni contre camille ni contre justement
jean michel jarre du voile alors jean
michel vernhes à embaucher aussi je
crois que c était un peu vexé disons
contrairement à ce que tu me disais non
moi j'ai attrapé le boulard non mais
faut que je réponde
tu me disais que j'avais attrapé le
bizarre je pense sont là je suis pas de
brognard d'un eu d'accord alors oui bon
déjà petite attaque est pas sympa mais
si aujourd'hui elle est supposée la
question non mais j'aime affirmé mais je
répondais lui on en fait je réponds pas
du tout parce que
cyril ne m'a pas embaucher de façon j'ai
pas posé mon cv et si demain je vais
avoir le boulard je n'ai pas eu à 20 ans
je n'aurai pas à 41 ans et si
effectivement j'avais le boulard je
pense que je ferai des doigts d'honneur
il serait un spectateur et j'insulte ray
des handicapés est d'ailleurs j'aimerais
te dire une chose vraiment non mais ne
fait pas l'étonné oui ces paraphes cour
d'école en asie mais écoute mon enfant
le truc c'est que à l'époque tu disais
que tu regrettait d'avoir fait des
choses avec cauet forcément et qui a
beaucoup de gens qui sont acharnés sur
toi comme à l'époque avec ce changement
qui est surtout à vis-à-vis de l'it et
vecta eu avec pharrell williams d'accord
et cela même un peu atteint un paroxysme
que c'est venu me chercher ta maman et
compagnie j'avais dit que je reçois des
menaces de mort et compagnie alors
maintenant mais toi la place quand vous
vous êtes en train d'envoyer les gens de
télé réalité certes que moi même que je
cautionne pas sur certaines émissions
parce que ce ne sont pas mes valeurs de
balancer de la bouffe et les maîtres à
jouer à kolontar
c'est d'autant plus que vous avez le
droit de donner un avis critique mais
vous n'avez pas le droit de parce que
toi aujourd'hui tu as une tribune t'as
ton siège c'est parfait mais demain le
jour du trouvera sur un tabouret et que
effectivement à l'appui no 6 de serre il
les autres eux ils n'ont pas à cette
tribune là ils peuvent pas se défendre
comme toi tu as plus de défendre
vis-à-vis de pharrell williams au visage
mais aussi nos métiers de lui mais c'est
ton métier mais c'est pas ton métier
d'insultés alors menacé la journée une
émission de divertissement gentiment mon
cerveau je suis content d'avoir vous
bien moi vous dire j'aimerais voilà que
tous les chroniqueurs et que vous
envoyons que tout - j'embrasse pas parce
que c'est quand même la mauricie
parvenez et après vous allez vous
embrasser
[Musique]